DEBATE BETENRATIC
NATOR RAL WARNOCK AN
REPUBLICAN HERSCHEL WALKER
ERTA
ACCUSATIONS THAT HPAID FORENIED
AN EX-GIRLFRNDRTN BACK
IN 2009.
LI
.
TO HAVR WARNOCK, PEOPL AND SAY
ANYTHISEAT, BUNOT  BECAUSE
TH TOO IMPORTANT TO
DOWN RIGHT NOW. FOR
>> MEM
WITH T TRUTH
HE SAYSMETHIN. WARNOCK BROUGHT
WALKER'S FALSE CLAT 'S
THAT LED TO THIS MOMEMENEL
NOW, I HAVE TO RESPOND TO AT.
>>VING ON, GENTLEMEN.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT SFU
I AM POLICE OFFICERS.
>> MR. WR, YOURE
AWARE OFVE A PROP.
THATALLOWED,YOU TO PUT THAOP AWA
BETT TE QUESTION IS D IT BENOUG
THPOK OFEBN THIS
IPED
E.RDICT REALLY
FOR HOWEVER LOW THE S FORS HE PH
>>HERE ARE A
NUMBER OF VOTERS TRULYEDHEE
BECAUSIT LAST
AND ANG AND RTAINLY RAN.
IN SUCH ZET
ENT IN GEOE IDEA T
IN T ST HAVE A ET WHAT  DO,T FEL
LIKE A LOT OF THESE CE
EYRY CLO
BUT E'S NOT N IGGL
OMT THISNT. THAE BA NOTWOUL BLOW
>> I WANT TO SHOW PEOPLE WHE
THIS RACE IS FOR NOW, BASICALLM
ALHAT CA  H 46.
THE PHENOMENATS ISE IS
ANOTHER RA IGEBERNATORIAL RACE N
THAT II THINK E PROBLEM FOR
HERS WR.N HE BRING THOSE BRIAN
VO HIM ITHEY ARE
GETTABLE?
AND IF NOT, WHT? THIGAP BETWEEN
CANDIDATES CONSIDERINGTHIS
IS SUCH A PARTISAN AGE.
TICKET-SPLITTING HAS LARDIEDCH
IN THE 198, TO 1U WOULD VEON
ATE  SEATS IN STATES THAT TH.IT
WEAKANDIDATE, G MUCH
REPUBLICAN OFF CE TO BREAK WITHM
L INM THIS
WEEK.
I AGREE THASN SOME WAYS EVEN MOR
, WAS THAT THE
PUSTICKID NOE,
ING ON T
PARTISANEND
ENM OVER THE
LINE.UBLICAN TICKETICAN V
U WI
LIKE HERSCHEL, SOMETHINGS
WRONG TH
INOME WALKER
KIND OF LEANING INTO THAT
HE I'VE HAVE NEEDED PSYCHIATRE,
IS GOOOUGH.E HO WORKI G>> I THF
- NU O
G TOOO
CANDIDATES AND SAY I CAN SEE
SER P
AND HAVING HIM LEAD MY S
RSR BE
A IN THESEATEVER REASON.
THAT'S A C
HAVE CLEAREDTO ADDRESS DURING
I DON'T THINK THERE WERE MAN
NOW. I'M G SAW TE
I THINK ONE OF THI
BE LOOKING AT OF HE IMPACOFFORMM
BRAIKEPRS TO BE IN
A AND SEW A LICANWI
TRUMP AK LIGHT PERFORMS.
FOR A COA HOT TOPIC.
FROM HIS SIS NOWACE FRONT RN BE
HIM, TO TRY TO FLIP THIS ISSUE
>> I
NOT HAVE A YOU
MAKING FUN OF IT OR TEG YOU
N'T ABLE T OR
YOU'REO SERVE, BUT
UNFOUNR IN
MY LIFG
>> WHAT OU
>> EXTRAORDINARY.
NOJUT NENT IHIT IS A DOCTOR,T T
ISANN'T BERA
ABOUT HIS NDS THE OF CRUELTY ON
TRYING HIS BEST TO DEAL WITHTER
IT'SOIEE WHICH ONE
IT EMPATOTHER
SIDE.
RIGHT NOITN
EMPATHETIC COUNTRY'LL SEE HOW I
DOCTOR KIND INTO ATLOF
HE D ANOTHERNTE WAS CONFRONTED
WITH HISAMS ATTACKS ON
HERE IS HOW HE RES TO
TH I HAVE TREMENDOUS COMPASSIOHA
ONS  DI PRECIATE THE CHALLENGESS
A AOFNEBLEM,  THIS
O  THE DAY
BEFORE>> I DON'T THINK THERESED
CAPTIONING ON E HEMAOS
CANICTY
A LOT OF QUESTD TERSET>>STTH T T
ART, LIKE, DON'T MOC
VOTERS
AMERICI THINK
KNOW THEY'VE NEEDEIAL  WHERTH
CAREEDED EXTRA CUL PER M THE UNS
K THAT'S WHY OINKS
POTENTIALLY GOOD
THE GOOD MESSAGE WOULD BE
HEE E IN SAY,
PERS WRE
THE SENATE NECESSARILY
INABOUT Y CAT JOB.
>> WHAABOUT S E ATE WAS NITI AD
NING THEACE IN A DIFFERE AT THE
POSITION IN PART BECAUSE ORSONAD
E REALIZIN IS PETTERMAN  HAS A
OCINT E
TAKEN A BACK SEAT TO THE
RSD THE FI
GOING ON BETWEEN
ATES.
>>HE
BRP,ICIANS W
DISA